bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de kiosques kiosque votre
magazine dédié à la culture sur saint
quentin en yvelines et ses environs tout
de suite les titres de ce mercredi 28
octobre
trois membres du groupe gaz deaves sont
en plateau pour nous parler musique et
nous présenter leurs prochains concerts
aux influences rock blues à la batterie
de guyancourt
le jeudi 12 novembre à 20h30 benjamin
bolland directeur du développement
social et culturel de la ville des
clayes-sous-bois nous rejoindre à tout à
l'heure pour nous présenter la
programmation pluriel de sa ville dans
le cadre de la célébration du centenaire
14 18
l'exposition le roi est mort à la
scénographie baroque l'exceptionnel vous
invite à découvrir tous les détails de
la mort du roi soleil de son autopsie à
ses funérailles
en passant par l'étiquette du deuil à la
cour et maintenant place à nos premiers
invités
trois membres du groupe gaz dit veulent
c'est bon pour l'accent qui donne un
cancer le jeudi 12 novembre à 20h30 à la
batterie de guyancourt
nous recevrons franck de loisy batteur
du groupe bonsoir pierre-maurice
chanteur et guitariste maintenant tout
comme walter batel bonsoir alors votre
route n'est pas au complet nous recevons
ce soir trois membres mais vous êtes 7 7
qui se sont rencontrés alors
configuration actuelle depuis deux ans
mais le groupe s'est fondée il ya une
dizaine d'années autour d'une passion
qui n'est pas la musique mais la moto ce
que vous pourriez nous expliquer un peu
la composition de ce groupe
les vrais motards en effet c'est à dire
que le en 2002
le groupe de motos d'orgeval dont on
fait un petit peu partie certaines
parties du groupe qui s'appelle les
devils broquin ça fait un petit jeu de
mots comme ça et donc on a un très très
vite sympathisé tous autour de la moto
et on avait une petite passion un peu de
notre côté aussi qu'ils étaient hors de
la moto qui s'appelait la musique et ça
a commencé un petit peu comme ça avec
jacques qui n'est pas présent sur le
plateau mais sur une table de jardin
derrière mon pavillon on avait fait une
petite répétition lors d'un d'une fête
pour le club de la moto on avait préparé
un petit quizz et d'ailleurs comment
franck nous aller enjoint aussi on avait
préparé des introductions de quelques
secondes et les gens devaient
reconnaître le titre et puis pour y
gagner des lots et puis de la bombe un
batterie d'ailleurs la première fois que
tu es venu je crois que tu étais sur un
un sou tu avais commencé à jouer sur un
saut avec jacques on avait joué un petit
peu de la guitare tous les deux et à
l'épreuve le démarrage de commentateurs
vous a rejoint alors le groupe au début
c'était trois personnes
ensuite il ya notre bassiste nono qui ne
jouait pas d'un instrument mais qui a
dit j'aimerais bien jouer avec vous qui
faisait un petit peu aussi partie du
club de moto ensuite après walter est
arrivé donc notre jeu c'est sur le sol
pratiquement du groupe qui est
professionnel moi j'ai rencontré nono en
fait comme ça on va dire par hasard on
est on est on a eu des soirées en commun
autour de la musique d'ailleurs et on a
tout de suite sympathisé et c'est vrai
qu'à l'origine avait une chanteuse était
invitée qui était avec vous là qui ne
fait plus partie du groupe et du coup
ben moi je suis arrivé simplement tant
que chanteur des parts dans le groupe g
je suis venu occuper cette place vacante
et puis il ya les huîtres amoral de ne
chanter uniquement le chantait libre en
ring voilà jeu parce que je suis avant
tout guitariste et
les professeurs de guitare vrai que
c'est mon univers et moi j'ai rejoint le
groupe parce que j'ai eu principalement
par affinités en fait parce que je me
suis tout de suite très bien entendus
non seulement avec nono qui vous suit
avec avec tout le monde on a partagé
beaucoup d'humour surtout on passe de
bons moments et c'est vrai que c'est une
aventure humaine d'amitié je pense plus
que plus que vraiment les musicales et
moi ça m'a permis de d'avoir un moyen de
continuer à faire de la musique mais par
passion simplement pas par un objectif
professionnel ou quoique ce soit d'autre
et c'est quelque chose qui ressort bien
dans votre musique alors musique comme
je le disais il est formé par le
répertoire blues et rock folk elles sont
vous m musicaux nos influences se trouve
chez chez henri gallagher chez jimi
hendrix chez que creedence clearwater
revival des gens comme ça qui ne date
pas tout à fait d hier mais qui sont
clairement nos influences c'est ce qu'on
essaye de locarno c'est c'est de créer
des morceaux qui sont dans cette
dans cette veine mais tout en étant le
plus actuel possible malgré tout et bien
je vous propose tout de suite et
d'écouter un extrait
b
ça
m
à
nous
alors walter vous le disiez tout à
l'heure vous vous êtes musicien
professionnel mais vous êtes le seul
avec fiona du groupe
tous les autres vous avez un métier
parallèle justement c'est ce qui vous
permettent de conserver cet esprit de
faire de la musique pour le plaisir lors
de la musique de qualité mais avant tout
pour le plaisir
franck par exemple absolument absolument
on a tous un métier
les uns sont consultants d'autres
moniteurs d'auto-école l'autre avocat
fin etc
et effectivement ça nous permet à la
fois de de déstresser 2 et se retrouve
et surtout avec avec des amis pour des
moments de partage d'amitié alors
justement pierre commence que vous
travaillez autour de la musique est ce
que vous créez les textes est ce que
vous prenez la musique est ce que je
vends alors oui on en a chaque mois on
est prôné assez polyvalent donc il ya
des textes qui ont été créés avec de la
musique qui a été fait soit par walter
benjamin titre d'exemple le seul morceau
je crois que j'ai composées je n'ai
jamais retenu par coeur et notre ami
notre ami walter qui le chante
voilà bon c'est ça a été composé un
petit peu comme comme beaucoup
d'artistes comme ça sur un coin de table
en faisant rouler également oui voila
voila tout à fait après on est tous les
vendredis d'accord dès vendredi soir ça
nous sert comme disait franck de soupape
puisqu'on a des métiers différents
et puis on se rejoint donc tous ensemble
autour d'instruments et il ya une
troisième mi temps où on faire ils ont
un petit pot entre nous pour avoir une
petite bière avec des copains ouais tout
à fait tout à fait est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu l'occasion walter tous ensemble
ou séparément de participer à une
résidence artistique
d'une certaine manière oui j'ai eu
l'occasion de participer notamment une
une émission de téléréalité sur internet
en fait qu'ils aient quelque chose j'ai
des goûts assez éclectique on va dire et
cette émission s'appelle le métal versus
tournament et s'était créé par parle par
des amis à moi qui ont mis ça en place
où les musiciens s'inscrivent et ils
sont tirés au sort de manière aléatoire
pour pouvoir former un groupe qui sera
filmé pendant deux jours en studio
le but étant de faire de composer dans
ce métal à la fin à la fin des deux
jours et bien c'est le cas également de
l'équipe du spectacle angels in america
qui participe actuellement à une
résidence artistique à la ferme de bel
ébat à guyancourt images de patrick jacq
du dixmude l'homosexualité thème déjà
cher aux militants tony que fleurs dans
les années 1980 ce dramaturge américain
il consacre une pièce de théâtre angels
in america pour laquelle il reçoit le
prix pulitzer en 1993 de nombreux soit
adapté cette fois ci cette pièce est
mise en scène à la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt lors d'une résidence
artistique et avait plusieurs enjeux il
y avait l'idée de parler de la maladie
dans la société de quel est le rapport
d'une société face à la maladie dans
notre société justement extrêmement
développé technologique de se dire
comment ce rapport-là reste très
archaïque et puis après il y avait le
côté très
éclectique de la pièce c'est vrai que
c'est une très grande fresque qui
mélange beaucoup de registres et ça
c'est un défi très excitant pour un
metteur en scène réinsuffler de la
réflexion autour des thèmes de la
maladie du sida et de l'homosexualité
c'est le défi que doivent relever les
comédiens pendant 4h30 de représentation
devant le public
une vraie performance qui traverse tous
les registres du comique au tragique du
grotesque alain team une scénographie
très proche de celle du cinéma a été
retenu pour cette grande fresque des
années 80 made in usa elle est créée
vraiment des séquences qui se passe dans
des endroits très différents donc on
sent qu'il l'a écrit comme un film et
nous l'un des enjeux en tout cas c'était
de rendre théâtrale ce dispositif
cinématographique de réfléchir aux liens
toujours entre théâtre et cinéma qui a
en tout cas nos moteurs et de du coup on
a décidé en tout cas nous d'en faire un
espace unique représentation attendus le
samedi 7 novembre à 18 heures à la ferme
de bel ébat de guyancourt retour sur
notre plateau avec trois membres du
groupe gaz dit veulent ce groupe de rock
et de blues
alors nous l'expliqué tout à l'heure à
la musique est avant tout une passion
et vous où est alors de moments festifs
comme la fête de la moto
vous aimez tous la moto des
anniversaires des mariages fêtes de la
musique et pour vous l'occasion de
monter sur scène c'est également la
récompense après des répétitions
hebdomadaires
walter moi je dirais que ça fait partie
des raisons c'est avant tout une
récréation je pense pour nous c'est
c'est un moment où on peut finalement
exprimé tout ce qu'ont tous qu'on passe
notre temps à répéter tout en laonnois
réunion hebdomadaire
je pense que c'est un moment où ou au
contraire on laisse éclater un peu
justement la bonne humeur et la
camaraderie qui entre nous dans ces
moments là et sur scène et on essaie de
partager ça avec avec le public qui
vient nous écoutent et qui vient nous
voir jouer tout simplement sur scène et
on pourra venir vous voir jouer
jeudi 12 novembre prochain 20h30 à la
batterie de guyancourt alors avant de
vous quitter je vous propose de
découvrir ensemble aux valentino artiste
complet auteur compositeur interprète et
guitariste originaire
trappes qui nous offre un nouveau projet
musical son album de cette petite est
intitulé krav maga parce que la vie
selon lui est un combat perpétuel
celui ci sera disponible dès le 31
octobre 2015 sur toutes les plateformes
de musique on écoute douceur son clip
officiel
je me jette je ne sais pas je n'ai
en ce qui te ra jamais
non
je suis à
et
monsieur
un peu de ce lot r'n'b mélangé à de la
rumba ce que moi ma spécialité c'est la
rumba congolaise africaine donc j'ai
voulu un peu m'amuser en fait et en même
temps parler de la vie en amour c'est ce
qui est la base de la vie c'est sans âme
où on ne peut pas on peut pas vivre en
tout cas aisément son père franck de
loisy walter batel et pierre maurice
merci d'être venus en plateau
aujourd'hui pour nous parler de votre
groupe gaz deaves et de votre prochain
concert on pourra vous voir sur scène à
la batterie jeudi 12 novembre 20h30 à
guyancourt
on poursuit notre émission avec
l'exposition tant attendu de la
programmation de l'année du château de
versailles dans le cadre du
tricentenaire de la mort de louis xiv
vous pourrez profiter de l'exposition le
roi est mort jusqu'au 21 février 2016
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
draperies noir tapisserie façon brocard
reconstitution du grand cénotaphe et
jeux de lumière une scénographie baroque
exceptionnelle pour la nouvelle
exposition au château de versailles
le roi est mort cette exposition accorde
à la scénographie une place toute
particulière parce que elle est tout à
fait dans l'esprit de ce que c'était car
toute la cérémonie les cérémonies
funèbres de louis xiv ont été organisées
par l'administration des menus plaisirs
et c'était des décors éphémères des
costumes et fait main tout était fait
pour la cérémonie pour ce temps de deuil
cette exposition permet de mettre en
lumière la mort de louis xiv survenu le
1er septembre 10 715 mettant fin au plus
long règne de la monarchie française de
l'autopsié aux funérailles du roi soleil
en passant par l'étiquette du deuil est
la cour tout le protocole y est détaillé
les règles de deuil étaient les
suivantes une couleur la plupart du
temps c'est le noir c'est qui est plus
important c'est la nature des vêtements
c'est tout ceci est très codifié et
notamment
la longueur par exemple la longueur du
manteau c'est les attributs comporte les
épées les livres que l'on tient à la
main les éventails les coiffures les
bijoux tous ces détails dépendent de
deux choses
cela dépend de la personne pour qui en
porte le deuil et ça dépend de la
personne qui porte le deuil la mort du
roi soleil marquent la fin de 72 ans
d'absolutisme royal et offre la
possibilité aux idées nouvelles du
siècle des lumières de se développer
les premiers pamphlet vont faire leur
apparition la mort de louis xiv c'est là
le début de la chute des jésuites en
france et c'est important c'est la fin
d'un gouvernement personnel est très
autoritaire plus de latitudes plus de
tolérance plus de possibilités dans le
domaine de l'édition et de la presse
il sera possible de profiter de cette
exposition très riche en informations au
château de versailles jusqu'au 21
février 2016 dans un bol en directeur du
développement social et culturel de la
vie des clayes-sous-bois nous a rejoint
en plateau bonsoir bonsoir
alors la ville des clayes-sous-bois a
reçu tout récemment le label centenaire
ce label convenait en fait aux villes et
qui propose une programmation riche
structurantes et plurielle autour du
centenaire au 14 août est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire un mot sur ce label
alors le label ea louis des données à
des projets municipaux ou associatifs
qui met en avant à la fois partenariat
entre autres associations ville qui
accompagne aussi l'éducation nationale
dans voilà l'éducation à ce premier
conflit
voilà qui a été important pour notre
histoire et puis qui permet aussi de
récolter des objets ou des mémoires
je dirais des archives ou des mémoires
enregistré 2 d'habitants des villes en
question
alors je disais que justement votre
programmation elle est très éclectique
et a pas forcément de lignes directrices
vous allez proposer cette exposition
aussi bien sur les tirailleurs
sénégalais que les sapeurs pompiers de
paris dans la grande guerre que les
gueules cassées que les poilus plus que
les siens pourquoi ce parti pris de ne
pas avoir choisi d'axer sur un thème
central
alors parce que c'est la première
édition que en fait c'est un c'est un
collectif qui s'est créé autour
d'énergie associative qui étaient
nombreuses au quai sous bois donc l'idée
de la ville c'était de de regrouper
toutes ses énergies et de dans cette
première année de faire quelque chose de
d'assez généraliste qui aborde tous les
sujets la première guerre mondiale tous
les sujets ça serait prétentieux mais en
tout cas une partie des grands sujets de
la première guerre mondiale
donc c'est pour ça que cette année n'y a
pas de thématique précise qui sera
peut-être le cas les années suivantes
mais voilà on a voulu vraiment laissé la
place à toutes les envies de
transmission qui existait au départ ce
projet et alors là on voit à l'écran
exposition que vous proposez
actuellement à l'espace philippe noiret
sur les sapeurs pompiers de paris dans
la grande guerre quelle a été leur rôle
particulier dans cette grande guerre
basse et voilà c'est moins connu
forcément que le rôle des produits en
première ligne mais les pompiers sont
intervenus à la fois dans la ddt la
destruction de l'industrie française
dans les bombardements dans le secours
aux
aux personnes voilà donc ça a été en
tout cas les pompiers de paris voilà une
grande activité pendant la première
guerre 14-18 et l'exposition résume bien
aussi ce travail un peu oublié parfois
voilà de ces hommes qui ont aussi donné
de leur vie pour beaucoup comme les
tirailleurs sénégalais une façon de
rendre hommage à différents acteurs
comme peut-être oui tout à fait à la
foire notre armée coloniale a été
primordial dans la première et dans la
deuxième guerre mondiale et voilà
c'était aussi grâce à l'association
solis et voilà on nous aurons d'ailleurs
un intervenant qui vient de dakar pour
nous parler voilà de tout de toute
l'oeuvre des tirailleurs sénégalais
alors justement donc dans votre
programmation vous allez proposer cette
exposition de conférences des sorties
scolaires sont organisés un spectacle
alors on ne peut pas détailler tous les
toutes les manifestations de cette
programmation et quels sont les temps
forts à retenir particulièrement le
alors le spectacle en particulier parce
que c'est vraiment un spectacle très
très riches qui ont joué plusieurs fois
au festival d'avignon était composé à
partir de lait trop beau poigne de
lettres de poilus voilà on est parti de
là on est parti c'est par on est parti
c'est l'auteur qui est parti de lettres
de poilus et qu'il y a qui les a un
petit peu compté voilà qui on a en a
fait un spectacle est tout à fait tendre
parfois très drôle aussi
voilà et qui aborde aussi tous les
aspects de la vie des tranchées voilà
c'est un vrai moment un vrai moment
intime
voilà seul sur scène voilà très très
fort et donc il y aura une programmation
pour les scolaires pour les 3e voilà et
puis notre programmation tout public le
6 novembre le soir il reste qu'il reste
des places donc je vous invite à venir à
l'espace noir et retirer vos places
vendredi 6 novembre à l'espace noir est
à 20h30
et je vous propose de regarder un
extrait de ce spectacle si un jour vous
recevez cette lettre
cette j'aurais été tués
alors ne pleurez pas trop je n'aurais
pas été malheureux et seul votre pensée
moratal et de l'amertume
dites-vous que ma mort glorieuse que
j'ai fait mon devoir de notre nom s'en
trouvera plus estimé est plus respecté à
part le spectacle est ce que d'autres
temps forts sont à retenir bien tous le
disent le 9 et le 10 nous avions tous
les élèves de cm2 voilà des écoles des
clayes-sous-bois pour leurs maîtres pour
à la fois qu'il voit les expositions et
leur mettre un petit livre qui s'appelle
le petit quizz de la grande guerre voilà
est l'auteur du livre monsieur tonna
sera présent pour animer la remise de
ceux de ce quiz qui est 100 questions
fondamentales voilà pourquoi qu'est ce
qu'un poids lui pour qu'on les appelait
poilus alors pourquoi alors poilus bon
c'est pas parce qu'ils ont des poils
contrairement à ce que beaucoup
d'enfants crois parce que il ya eu une
hygiène importante quand même dans les
tranchées au niveau de la barre parce
que sinon les masques à gaz ne pouvait
vous ne pouvez pas être portées donc
voilà poilus à l'époque ça voulait dire
les braves
voilà c'était la signification de poilus
voilà pourquoi le terme de poilus donc
voilà c'est un petit quizz qui est à la
fois ludique mais qui aussi permet aux
enfants de retenir pas mal de choses
alors en plus d'avoir obtenu le label la
ville les clés sont voix présente deux
particularités vous avez retrouvé la
trace de quatre points luc les siens qui
ne sont pas inscrits sur votre monument
aux morts et qui ne seront l'année
prochaine et également la tresse d'un
livre alors dunks les siens qui a
participé à la guerre de 14 18 qui est
aujourd'hui décédé est un livre qui
fourmille de détails et de photos tout à
fait ces salles aventure collective du
collectif c'est que au fur et à mesure
voilà des réunions des le bouche à
oreille fait que les gens nous ramène
voilà des choses donc la découverte de
quatre poilus effectivement qui ne sont
pas inscrits sur notre monument aux
morts donc on va travailler tout cette
année voilà en particulier avec les
écoles pour pour les remettre à
l'honneur
là ça c'est important et puis le livre
de monsieur le fort voilà qui est un clé
siens qui était le petit fils d'un des
combattants dans un terminal qui n'était
pas que les siens voilà son nom n'était
pas que les siens mais lui a retrouvé
voilà un livre qui est très très riches
parce qu'il est rempli de photos ce qui
est assez rare non et non les parcours
dans les histoires de poilus voilà qui
nous racontent toute son aventure
voilà à berlin et puis après sur le sur
les tranches et dorian donc voilà c'est
aussi une chance pour les
clayes-sous-bois d'avoir ce style de
support parce que c'est tout à fait
voilà transmissibles et en particulier
aux plus jeunes
largement volant merci d'être venus
aujourd'hui en plateau pour nous
présenter une partie de la programmation
des clés se voit et on pourra retrouver
toute la programmation complète sur le
site de l'espace noiret ou prendre des
renseignements au numéro qui s'affiche à
l'écran on continue le kiosque avec
notre rendez vous cinéma que pensez-vous
des films à l'affiché cette semaine vous
impressions recueillies au micro de
camille lambert
oui j'aime et eu beaucoup aimé qui a vu
le sat enfin voila je crois avant tout
ça donc oui c'était un moment donné
c'était vraiment très intense
par rapport à ce que j'ai vu d'amenabar
c'est pas celui que je préfère mais si
on
bien c'est du bon mot divertissement et
non suspecte un très très beau film très
belle histoire l'histoire d'une passion
ça vous prend même quand on a le vertige
en examen on est pris par cette histoire
merveilleux c'était très bien c'était
très bien joué il ya rigolo s'est bien
marré dany boon était un très bon
artiste mais c'est vrai que quand on
fait un rapport avec les ch'tis on est
un petit peu un petit peu déçu quand on
voit ces films comme ça on ceci dit là
et ce sont des très bons acteurs
c'est comme dit madame un peu loufoque
dans l'aube sommes à chaud ça très bien
c'est déjanté c'est surtout il s'agit là
avec kate farrell en anglais aussi
impeccable j'étais agréablement surprise
mais c'est un film est d'une certaine
façon c'est pour un certain public
mais c'est pas mal quand même et ça fait
du bien de voir que l'une farrell
dans un rôle comme ça aussi cette
semaine c'est lui beaucoup ont dû signer
7 des encours qui nous donne son avis de
professionnel sur les nouveautés de ce
mercredi 28 octobre
mon coup de coeur cette semaine fait au
coeur de signer sept c'est le dernier
film de ridley scott
alors ridley scott s'est pas c'est
jamais mauvais mais c'est pas toujours
extraordinaire je pense à prometheus son
avant-dernier film mais celui-là il
réussit s'appelle seul sur mars avec
matt damon à l'affiché je vais pas vous
raconter l'histoire ça dure deux ans 24
c'est un film qui a été tourné
véritablement en 3d donc il faut essayer
de le voir en 3d on peut se voir en 2d
mais c'est une vraie 3d je tiens à
préciser
et donc c'est sur nos écrans à partir de
mercredi
et puis un deuxième petit coup de coeur
quand même pour julie delpy que j'aime
beaucoup parce que elle sort un film là
une comédie avec dany gounod qu'elle se
rapproche un petit peu du grand public
qui s'appelle lolo et qui est très
réussie avec aussi karine viard donc on
a aussi en sortie nationale
aujourd'hui aussi les sept lots à mon
fils c'est le lot jean rené très content
de vous rencontrer jean venait toujours
un cinéma je vous invite à l'avant
première du film à vif à l'ugc ciné cité
de skywest en vo sous-titrée mardi 3
novembre à 20h une comédie dramatique
d'une heure quarante avec bradley cooper
sénia miller et notre yvelinois omar sy
qui vous fera pénétrer le monde de la
haute gastronomie et la pression qui
repose sur les chefs étoilés on envoie
un extrait
oh merde je fais c'est d'ouvrir un
nouveau restaurant il ya au moins douze
personnes qui mettront sa tête à prix
souhaitant réfléchir à ce que tu m'as
fait c'est cool ok on était comme des
frères trois ans sans le moindre signe
qu'est ce que tu cherches
je veux ouvrir le meilleur restaurant du
monde et avant de nous quitter je vous
propose quelques dates à noter dans vos
agendas rendez vous mercredi 4 novembre
à 15 heures au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines scène
nationale pour danser qui nous incombent
chanter sur les arcanes de l'amour entre
les enfants et leur papa
une belle histoire de famille en forme
de haïkus mercredi 4 jeudi 5 novembre à
19h30 vendredi 6 à 21h et samedi 7
novembre à 17 heures rendez-vous prisme
d'elancourt pour c'est un peu compliqué
d'être l'origine du monde mêlant
astucieusement sphère publique et sphère
privée la pièce saute fébrilement d'un
registre à l'autre pour décrire un
parcours de combattante qui passent des
moments de panique à des situations
pleines d'humour et enfin samedi 7
novembre à 20 heures 30 à l'estaminet de
magny les hameaux
vous pourrez assister à la finale du
tremplin des voix organisé par
l'association la voix en scène
spécialisé dans le coaching vocal et
scénique fin du que ce que pour cette
semaine je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine mercredi 4 novembre pour un
programme en théâtre et en exposition
très bonne soirée à tous